[Música]
sou filha da dona mary pretinha não sabe
ler nem escrever
acredita que o casamento deve ser pra
sempre o meu pai já falecido era
branquinho com os olhos bem azuis
eles se conheceram em curitiba casaram
tiveram dois filhos
até aí uma família normal como qualquer
outro
no entanto no auge dos meus oito anos eu
descobri que a minha família diferente e
eu lembro exatamente o dia dessa
descoberta estava uma confusão na minha
casa o meu pai estava na cozinha
conversando com algumas pessoas
estranhas à minha mãe estava no quarto
chorando muito muito muito muito
e é na minha cabeça de criança achei que
eles estavam se separando pra mim era o
pior senado então imaginei isso eles
estão se separando
eu fui lá falar com a minha mãe para
tentar compreender o que estava
acontecendo e aí ela me relatou que
aquelas pessoas que estavam falando com
meu pai tinham ido cobrar o pedágio do
mês mas não tinha dinheiro pra pagar e
se eles não se tem um desing levar o meu
pai para longe
na hora eu pensei poxa porque você não
chama a polícia para resolver esse
problema e para minha surpresa a minha
mãe disse que era a própria polícia que
tinha vindo cobrar o meu pai
naquele momento eu fiz algumas
conclusões
e emendou a outra pergunta mãe japonesa
está errado aqui quem manda na pista
então minha mãe disse que o juiz era o
único que poderia mandar na polícia é um
tal juízes mas a mãe está fugindo da
polícia
ela só balançou a cabeça e disse que sim
chorando ela não queria me contar aquilo
mas eu conclui
e eu estava certo naquele momento
apenas oito anos eu havia preveem
precisem presenciado a primeira de uma
série de episódios de corrupção policial
marginalização econômica e de
ilegalidades
a partir daquela conversa nunca mais foi
a mesma
lembro que eu como meu quarto chorar um
monte rezá enfim e passando um tempo
depois é chegar a uma outra conclusão é
que naquela mesma conversa naquele mesmo
dia eu havia entendido que nós filhos de
pessoas que estão presas o que já foram
presas
herdamos um preconceito por causa dos
erros dos nossos pais
isso é um fato e justamente por saber
disso uma mulher orientou a minha mãe
existisse no meu pai
o pagamento de um bom colégio pra mim
pro meu irmão no bairro distante
isso significava duas coisas primeiro
nos proteger dos preconceitos que as
atitudes do meu pai nos traziam né
em segundo isso significava nos dá
acesso a uma educação de qualidade então
fez feito esse acordo que acionar ao sem
se dar conta à minha mãe que é
analfabeta ela tava quebrando um ciclo e
contrariando algumas afirmações muito
populares aqui no brasil que dizem que o
fruto não vai muito longe do pé e que
filho de peixe peixinho é
e agora imagina filho de bandido
quais seriam as perspectivas minha e do
meu irmão bem entrei no colégio
no colégio a minha visão de mundo
tornam-se duplicada a vida que as outras
crianças relatavam não era nem um pouco
semelhante com a minha e ok isso fez
parte da minha vida por muito tempo
o meu pai era foragido
então isso significava que 24 horas por
dia de janeiro a janeiro a gente estava
o tempo todo em alerta o tempo todo em
alerta porque a qualquer momento poderia
prendê-lo ou extorqui-lo isto aquilo
aconteceu com muito mais freqüência
lembro uma vez que não estava no ensino
médio ainda mais
eu estava dando a minha mãe a seca louça
não estava aqui com o prato a janela da
cozinha da minha casa dá de frente para
a rua
eu estava aqui eu vi dois carros
passando quando esses dois carros
passando com esse movimento a minha casa
estava sendo invadida de novo e vários
episódios de extorsão e chegou um
momento que eu não agüentava
mas isso não estava mais essa tensão ano
aguentava mais
é flagrante extorsão e se repetirá n
vezes e meu pai que sendo capa de jornal
até que chegou um momento que eu pedi
para o meu pai e cumprir a pena dele o
pai por favor vai e cumpra sua pena
óbvio que esse pedido não foi assim
nada.de por favor me dá uma água claro
que não
lembro também nessa cena e depois foi
entre essas pessoas invadiram minha casa
eram três pessoas eles vão negociar mais
um acerto que é quando você paga para
você não ser preso
só que eu olhava e eu ouvia nem de longe
eu não ligo para tirar esse dinheiro eu
sabia que ele não tinha dinheiro e aí eu
resolvi interviú então aos 14 anos eu
fiz a minha primeira negociação e eu
falei por favor vai a gente dá um jeito
a gente dá um jeito não sei como a gente
dá um jeito mas acreditava que a gente
dá um jeito
e aí eu lembro que uma dessas pessoas eu
sou baixinha gente muito mais alta do
que é o que me pegou aqui
miguel e me disse você nunca vai ser
nada seu pai vai morrer e apodrecer na
cadeia de câncer me colocou no chão
enfim várias outras coisas aconteceram
meu pai foi cumprir a pena dele entrou e
saiu pela frente do complexo médico
penal
lá em curitiba não tinha consciência do
que esse pedido ea representar o que a
partir do momento que você entra no
sistema prisional há uma série é um
universo paralelo
então isso significou muitos sábado sem
filas e muitas revistas vexatórias que
não achava enfim ser tranquilas mas não
e além de todas essas experiências
físicas emocionais
a partir do momento que meu pai foi
preso a primeira vez eu não era mais a
beatriz a minha identidade mudou
completamente
eu era filha do cara da esquina que foi
preso
para isso eu morria de vergonha eu
desejei isso me várias vezes eu sentia o
peso de todos os olhares jogadores
eu não tinha como eu fingi surdez
diante de todas as salas preconceituosas
que eram verbalizado sem um mínimo de
empatia não tinha como eu sumir não
tinha
e além disso eu me sentia suja
eu tenho nojo de mim até nojo do meu
passado e esse sentimento
ele era potencializado com muitos
questionamentos que ficavam 24 horas por
dia na minha cabeça como por exemplo
será que os erros do meu pai definiriam
todo o meu futuro
até que um dia eu conseguiria cursar uma
faculdade
até que um dia teria uma vida normal
depois de andar na rua entende tudo vida
normal de não ter medo de que encontrar
ou de simplesmente construir uma família
ao lado de uma pessoa honesta e como eu
me sentia suja como tinha nojo eu não me
sentia digna de ter isso por muito tempo
eu não me senti digna de ter isso
agora imaginem como você reagiria ao ver
o seu pai ou a sua mãe privados de
liberdade
qual impacto que isso geraria na
formação do seu caráter ano nas suas
escolhas
nós filhos de presos
somos o que somos culpados somos vítimas
somos futuros marginalizados porque o
porto não vai muito longe do pé
somos o que eu não sei não tenho essas
propostas mas nós somos invisíveis nós
somos estigmatizados
quando a gente erra a primeira coisa que
nos falam é fruto não cai muito longe do
pé e não tem dados sobre o número exatos
de filhos de presos que existem no
brasil tem 730 e mais 730 mil presos no
brasil compõe o banco nacional de
monitoramento de prisões
se eu fizer uma conta muito básicas que
se cada homem tiver um filho já uma
população muito grande ea gente não
conhece essa população
a gente não sabe quais serão esses
futuros e contudo um todo esse contexto
eu também me tornando maps
então eu sou aquela pessoa que eu
preciso provar tudo o que puder precisa
me apoiar na ciência todos os
sentimentos
então todo esse caos interno esses
questionamentos
eu descobri que tem diversas áreas do
conhecimento que estudam isso que
estudam essa população carcerária muito
mais lá fora do que no brasil
no brasil apenas cinco artigos sobre
esses temas sobre os filhos do sistema
prisional
enfim eu descobri andréia boro que é
mestre em antropologia social pela usp
que afirma que
a família de um preso significa na
prática em conviver do mesmo estigma
social que ele e toda a família da minha
mãe
toda família da minha mãe toda a família
do meu pai me julgavam eu e meu irmão
crescemos com os olhares esperando que a
gente desse errado mas até hoje essa
torcida se mantém muito enganada e muito
calada
aquele acordo educacional da minha mãe
transformou transforma completamente a
minha vida
no dia que eu recebi o telefonema
falando que eu tinha sido aprovada vai
ajudar o ensino médio na escola técnica
da ufpr
eu desliguei o telefone a polícia
invadiu mais uma vez a minha casa tinha
sido preso
mais uma vez na hora as coisas podem
sair mas a minha preocupação era ok da
onde eu vou tirar 600 reais para comprar
os livros que eu vou usar durante três
anos na escola técnica da ufpr
eu não fazia idéia geralmente aos 15 16
anos os adolescentes estão descobrindo a
sua sexualidade em das primeiras festas
sempre mas eu só queria saber quando vai
voltar pra casa como a gente ia se
manter enquanto ele estivesse preso como
que a gente ia ter o que comer nesse
período
como é que as coisas vão se resolver a
minha única preocupação
apesar de todo esse contexto eu acabei
conquistando uma bolsa preta relações
internacionais e conheci áreas incríveis
do passe do do conhecimento enquanto
estava tendo as minhas primeiras aulas
de direitos humanos eu estava
vivenciando as revistas vexatórias então
direitos humanos para quem toda vez que
passava uma revista ou chato olha eu
lembrava disso quem aqui vive na prática
os direitos humanos no brasil não sair
eu acabei construindo uma carreira na
área de empreendedorismo social de um
enorme privilégio de construir essa
carreira seguir colocando enfim
gente de tudo é que contraria as
pesquisas internacionais que afirmam que
70% dos filhos de presos viram a ser
encarcerados prazer eu sou os 30 por
cento
[Aplausos]
acredito que toda vez eu acredito que
toda vez que uma pessoa vai presa
significa que nós falhamos como o
cenário que nós falhamos a inclusão
econômica que nós falhamos em políticas
públicas
não basta apenas lotar os presídios
quem ficou do lado de fora esperando o
pai ou a mãe voltar quem vai garantir a
essas crianças a esses adolescentes e
jovens que eles tenham a oportunidade de
construir um futuro diferente dos seus
pais ou quais as redes de apoio existem
para que essas crianças não repitam os
mesmos erros dos seus pais também não
sei
no universo do crime o silêncio é uma
lei
se você fala demais você vai aparecer
morto
eu cresci ouvindo isso então tá aqui tá
sendo contrário ao que houve durante 30
anos da minha vida
além disso o silêncio é um artigo 5º do
código penal brasileiro
você pode falar de permanecer em
silêncio você escolhe
no meu caso silêncio tornou se um fardo
com um peso uma negação a minha
identidade
quanto mais eu percorri o caminho certo
da vida o quanto mais eu acessava a
lugares que nunca imaginei que acessar
maior era o peso do meu silêncio e eu me
dei conta que o meu silêncio só estava
reforçando a invisibilidade que milhares
de crianças jovens e adolescentes sofrem
todos os dias
em nós por serem filhos de presos o meu
silêncio estava reforçando um estigma
social
isso ficou muito claro então com uma
coragem e com uma vontade enorme de
creme libertar esse fardo de silêncio eu
decidi criar meios de potencializar
pessoas que têm histórias como a minha
com o objetivo de dar ainda mais voz a
elas mas principalmente de mostrar para
elas mesmas que o passado não pode
continuar definindo o futuro
nós não somos servos dos nossos pais nós
somos maiores do que qualquer tipo de
preconceito que um dia nos verbalizaram
bem consigo aprendendo todos os dias que
passado algum pode definir o nosso
futuro não importa o nosso contexto nós
temos o direito de escrever a nossa a
nossa própria história independente de
qualquer coisa
acredito também que a gente não pode
aceitar rótulos
não podemos aceitar notas e mais do que
isso nem sempre a gente tem controle
sobre o que os nossos pais fizeram então
parem de nos outro lar o parem de nos
calar
parem de dizer que o nosso futuro já
está definido nem sempre
filho de peixe peixinho é nós estamos em
eterna construção e podemos sim ser o
que quisermos ser obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]